you and you won't realize it that's the
other thing that the studies show you
ask the kids do you think that these
songs are changing you they said well
it's totally ridiculous it's just a song
I'm not going to go out and do that
stuff
the kids have no awareness that yes how
you choose to entertain yourself is
changing who you are these songs are
activating like these Demons by
listening to Drake and Bruno Mars It's
Gonna Change you I don't wanna be that
girl anymore don't allow your children
to watch the Disney Channel Nickelodeon
or Nick Jr now everyone's worked up over
Andrew Tate why is nobody going after
Bruno bars for exploiting women like
this that's a fair question inshallah
inshallah God will greetings of peace
and welcome to the dean's show my next
guest Dr Leonard Sachs MD PhD is an
American psychologist and a practicing
family physician and author of why
gender matters boys adrift girls on the
edge and the New York Times best-selling
author collapse of parenting
he's also has some things to say about
listening to Drake Lady Gaga cardi B and
the like I don't know why I didn't want
her to do this
song shake it or like any Joe songs
because
it's like
these songs are activating like these
demons you know what I'm saying like
I don't want to be that girl anymore
like
like I just I just want to be a mother
you know what I'm saying like
I don't want to be that old party
anymore I left that lifestyle
a long time ago bro like I just I don't
want to be that anymore and the
dangerous effects of it
without further Ado let's bring out my
special guest Dr Leonard Sachs
[Applause]
and his final messages
um
how are you doing I'm okay how are you
good good thank God good to have you on
the program
thanks for inviting me
so me and you go way back you probably
don't know that but uh I read one of
your books long time ago and I was
really impressed I believe it was girls
on the edge
and then recently I had one of my
students my Jiu Jitsu students uh Dr uh
Joe he'll be really excited I got you on
a program he said man you got to get
this guy in the show here we go
on The Dean show cold and wet here in
Philadelphia but otherwise we're doing
good great great let's get right into uh
the topic here uh I got a lot of things
I want to cover with you let's get right
into this modern songs you call it sex
for money you know and the dangerous
effects uh saying cardi B and Megan the
stallion advise women to ask for car
while having sex with a man adding that
a man paid my tuition in return for sex
so the question is what kind of mindset
does this create for young
impressionable Minds
yeah my first recommendation for parents
is no earbuds no headsets you need to
know what your kids are listening to and
the most many of the most popular songs
in the United States are really toxic
um carding me making the stallion the
song you're referring to is WAP w-a-p
I'm not going to say what that stands
for because it's obscene and it is it is
meant to be obscene uh
and
it is a very degraded and uh
sad uh perspective on The Human
Experience that that uh
you have sex
not because it's part of a loving
relationship but uh because you wanna
you want this man to give you money for
it
um or Bruno Mars and his Grammy uh
award-winning song that's what I like
approaches a woman he doesn't know and
again offers her money for sex turn
around and drop it for a player because
that's what I like and the recording
Academy said yes that's the best song
that's the best United States has to
offer six Grammys for that song
parents need to be aware that American
popular culture
not all of it but much of it now is
really toxic and is uh promoting a view
of human experience and of man and woman
that
really is harmful and leads to anxiety
depression disengagement you know I want
to commend you I mean you're very brave
you know to come out you know you don't
see a lot of people in your position
they kind of just go with the flow kind
of you know scared to speak out against
these things but so I want to start off
with commending you to Having the
courage to come out and address these
things so that was my next question with
Bruno Mars you talk about him winning
earning six Grammys for his song that's
what I like in which he offered a woman
gold jewelry and shot a shopping spree
in Paris if she just turned around and
drop it for a player because that's what
I like so so I'm asking you know what
what is this teaching men
everyone worked up you know everyone's
worked up over Andrew Tate why is nobody
going after Bruno bars for exploiting
women like this
uh that's a fair question brothers and
sisters we've all had loved ones that
passed away a mother a father a brother
sister a close family member for one of
the mercies of our Dean Islam is that we
can have an intention to do good deeds
on our loved ones behalf and what
greater of a continuous Good Deeds than
investing on their behalf in the Deeds
Center a Masjid and megadawa Center that
will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
[Music]
is it here yeah
um I certainly don't want to get into a
comparison of Bruno Mars and Andrew Tate
that's just not that's not going to be
productive for most of you no we don't
have to we don't have to do that uh but
I'm just asking a fair question that's
it I'm just asking a fair question the
deeper question is
what has happened to American culture
you know I've lived in this country all
my life
born and raised in the United States and
a generation ago
two men Loggins and Messina had a huge
hit in this country with their song
Danny's Song even though we ain't got
money I'm so in love with you honey
everything will bring Jane a joy and in
the morning when I Rise bring a tear of
joy to my eyes and tell me everything's
going to be all right even though we
ain't got money
love is more important than money that's
a very healthy message
I'm so in love with you honey that's
that's that's true that's right to teach
kids that money's not the most important
thing
love and courtesy and respect are the
most important thing and that was the
message that was being sent by American
popular culture a generation ago
not anymore the most popular shows the
most popular Tick Tock videos the most
popular songs many of them not all but
many of them communicate what I call in
my book the collapse of parenting I call
the culture of disrespect American
popular culture now teaches kids that
it's cute that it's funny that it's cool
to be disrespectful not only to adults
and to parents but to one another you'll
see American kids wearing t-shirts which
signs with signs that say things with uh
slogans that say things like uh you look
better on Facebook or I'm not shy I just
don't like you uh you know and I was
speaking to kids in Scotland and I was
showing them some of these you don't see
these outside the United States
incidentally or in Canada you'll see
them in the United States and Canada but
nowhere else
uh
and I was showing these uh when I spoke
to kids in in perthshire north of
Edinburgh Scotland and I showed them
some of these t-shirts and the and the
kids in scoffing were
puzzled
they they wondered why would you go out
in public with a t-shirt that says to
the whole world I'm not shy I just don't
like you the kids in Scotland that
didn't seem funny it just seemed rude
and childish but American kids born and
raised and immersed in this culture of
disrespect they think this is funny you
know I'm a family doctor in my own
practice a mom of an eight-year-old an
eight-year-old boy was saying to me he's
gotten so disrespectful and talking back
where is he getting this and I said do
you have the Disney Channel
uh Nickelodeon Nick Jr they said oh sure
I said you need to turn it off you need
to prohibit Disney Nickelodeon Nick Jr
and three weeks later mom told me it
stopped wow he was he was learning this
from the Disney Channel the Disney
channel is now full of shows that teach
kids that it's cute and funny to be
disrespectful to parents what was that
what was that uh advice again that you
gave simple advice what was it
don't allow your children to watch the
Disney Channel Nickelodeon or Nick Jr
not all television is bad you know I
don't have a problem with the Cooking
Channel or National Geographic
but great advice Nickelodeon Nick Jr
it's teaching this culture of disrespect
uh you got shows where the parents are
clueless idiots and the kids know better
than the parents do and this is supposed
to be funny like a Dog with a Blog uh
where the the dog is always smarter than
the the father who supposedly a school
psychologist but knows nothing about
kids and and that he's the joke he's the
butt of the joke this is true of a lot
of American television Modern Family the
straight dad is always an idiot his
three kids are always wiser than their
dumb bumbling dad that the idiot father
has become a mainstream image in
American popular television and it is
not helpful it's not even true uh you
know in my own practice as a family
doctor most the dads are not idiots and
and bumbling fools but American popular
culture now now portrays them that way
uh we can talk about why that's so but
the the bottom line for parents is you
need to be on your guard American
popular culture is now often a vector of
this culture of disrespect
let's get into one more very popular or
very well-known figure Drake in one of
his popular songs you quote this Jimmy
Cooks the sexually explicit and
profanity lace lyrics too graphic for
ifs to print but the New York Times
revealed praise reviewer praise Drake
for his lyrical vividness it's so
sexually explicit but the question is
what can listening to Drake from a
psychological perspective teach you you
know teach you respect teach you to
respect women or just use women as
objects yeah we don't have to guess we
actually have studies where researchers
have followed kids over time and and
so the way to conceptualize these
studies if you've got two kids and 12
years of age and they don't differ on
how they view women or how they view
sexuality and then one kid is listening
to Drake and and that kind of hip-hop
and the other kid is listening to
something else listening to I don't know
Taylor Swift
uh and the kid who's listening to Drake
three years later is much more likely to
think that sex is transactional that you
pay money for sex that uh it's okay for
a man to hit a woman
the what you listen to how you choose to
entertain yourself
changes who you are this is especially
true for children and teenagers uh
there's I hope people won't be offended
if I quote a line from the Hebrew Bible
Proverbs chapter 4 23.
above everything else guard your heart
because everything you do flows from it
guard your heart guard your heart
guard your heart because everything you
do flows from it how you choose to
entertain yourself is changing who you
are if you choose to entertain yourself
by listening to Drake and Bruno Mars
It's Gonna Change you yeah you and you
won't realize it that's the other thing
that the studies show you ask the kids
do you think that these songs are
changing you they said well it's totally
ridiculous it's just a song I'm not
going to go out and do that stuff
the kids have no awareness that yes how
you choose to entertain yourself is
changing who you are so
parents have to be
in charge
and have to say no you're not allowed to
listen to that stuff I'm going to know
what you're listening to and you're not
allowed to listen to that and and
parents have to be out front because if
your kid lives in the United States it's
not reasonable it's not fair to expect
your 12 year old if the other kids are
listening to Drake what is your kid
supposed to say well I don't want to
listen to that because it defends my
modesty I mean how is a kid even
supposed to know the words to say and
let alone say them you have to allow the
kid to say hey my parents have installed
this filter on my phone I'm not able to
listen to that or if I do listen to it
they'll get an alarm on bark and and
I'll lose my device and I do encourage
I'd strongly advise parents to install
parental monitoring software out there
on any device that has internet access
to limit what your kids are listening to
warn your kids look yeah I'm sure you
can get around it but I'll know what
you're doing because the device is going
to show me you're not allowed to listen
to that stuff because it's bad parents
need to have the confidence
to limit govern and guide what their
kids are doing and they need to
understand that the culture has become
very toxic
it's not the culture of 20 years ago or
50 years ago it's a toxic culture and
that means parents got to do more than
our parents did
well you mentioned the heart it reminded
me of a statement from uh Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him who mentioned
something in a similar effect about the
heart guarding the heart he said there
was a morsel of Flesh in the body
meaning the heart if it's sound the
whole body will be sound so this is so
refreshing to hear a physician to go you
know into something like this of the
heart and um you know if more people
would gravitate towards this this is
something that can help to alleviate a
lot of these ills that are happening no
one's connecting it to the Drakes to the
cardi B's but now we have good enough
evidence you quote that the the kind of
music kids I mean obviously even adults
listen to influence their beliefs
attitudes and behavior and also you
quote in a long cohort study researchers
found that teens who listen to music
were degrading sexual content are more
likely to engage in sexual risky
behaviors and you just elaborated
elaborated on this you know this is this
is uh so so profound many people are not
they're naive and not making these
connections so there's handing over the
iPhone you know and says you know buying
you know buying these kids for the kids
but you know the average doctor you know
or psychologist is not making this
connection they're getting to hear it
for the first time here and for some
people like wow it's just you know it's
an aha moment
so um well it takes courage because when
you yeah you definitely got it you're
definitely you're gonna limit what they
do they may very well say none of the
other parents do that
and that may well be the case
but again you have to have the courage
as a parent to say I'm not their dad I'm
your dad and
that means it's my responsibility
to limit govern and guide what's your
what you're experiencing uh and again a
major objective for my book the collapse
of parenting is to empower parents to
give parents that confidence
to stand up and do the right thing uh
and the original title of that book the
title of the book I sent to the
publisher was the collapse of American
parenting and the subtitle was when most
kids will now be better off raised
outside North America and again I've
I've spoken for uh many
Muslim communities across North America
and many of those parents
our immigrants and we're not born in
this country and
they're struggling with the Defiance and
disrespect that they encounter I spoke
for the Islamic Association of Greater
Detroit
and after my talk uh husband and wife
who were born and raised in Syria but
have lived here for many years they have
four kids uh they normally speak Arabic
at home but they told me that when their
oldest son wants to be defiant or
disrespectful
he switches to English the parents told
me that his whole body language changes
he slouches he gets a smirk on his face
he starts speaking to us in English and
and dad said it's like Justin Bieber
just walked into the house Justin Bieber
wow English has become the language of
disrespect so one of the recommendations
I have when I speak for Muslim
communities is if you the parent
we're born outside the United States if
you are fluent in another language speak
that language at home make sure your
kids are fluent in your native language
find other families that speak that
language make connections with them
because American English-speaking
culture is now really toxic and if you
can connect to a different culture and
show kids that there's a different
culture where it's not cool to be
defined and disrespectful and connect
kids to other families who speak that
language and enjoy that music that's
really helpful because it gives kids a
perspective that hey Drake and Bruno
Mars and and Lady Gaga and and cardi B
they're not the whole world there's
another culture there are other cultures
out there American culture is not the
only culture that's a very helpful
message to communicate to your kid
you also quote in your article I want to
touch upon this I was really blown away
and you kind of know this from watching
uh I Love Lucy and whatnot but you know
they did a study on this where
researchers you quote in UCLA analyzing
the most popular American shows
targeting children and teens found that
the most popular shows from the 1960s
through the 1990s taught kids
thought kids what's most important is do
a doing the right thing being a good
friend telling the truth even if it
hurts but in more recent popular shows
such as Survivor and American Idol the
focus is on winning and becoming famous
I think this is just being this is nice
compared to all the other stuff that's
out there you know please talk more
about about the study yeah so this is a
UCLA study where they looked as you said
at the most popular TV shows targeting
children and teenagers and they found
from 1967 through 1997 even though the
shows were very different the message
was the same as you just said it's all
about doing the right thing being a good
friend telling the truth even if it
hurts and that was true whether you're
talking about The Andy Griffith Show in
1967 or Buffy the Vampire Slayer in
1997. but then between 1997 and 2007
everything switched and suddenly being
famous which had been the least
important thing
became the most important thing in shows
like Survivor iCarly American Idol
Suddenly It's All About winning uh doing
the right thing that's going to get you
voted off the island and it's gotten
only worse since that time so we have
really good research showing that
American culture changed and the change
most dramatically between 1997 and 2007
and the researchers wondered why is that
why did the culture change and the
answer they give is social media
uh social media transformed American
culture suddenly it was all about how
many likes you get how many followers
you have and it's only gotten worse uh
uh since 2007. uh so
parents again have to be on on their
guard and and you need to really limit
what your kids are doing on YouTube what
they're doing on tick tock
and again the parental monitoring apps I
have no affiliation with any of them but
you gotta choose one of them to put on
any device that has internet access
because it's not reasonable for you as a
busy parent to be constantly hovering
over your kid's shoulder and I don't
expect you to but the the apps will do
that and explain to your kid look it's
my job as your parent to limit govern
and guide what you're doing online and
so this app is going to show me what
you're doing it's going to stop you from
doing some of this stuff and it's going
to report to me what you're doing and if
I see you doing something bad
you may lose the device great advice I
mean amazing great advice in your book I
remember certain things from it that
really stood out particularly this book
girls on the edge and you talk about the
performance of girls this is what I
vaguely remember but it just it was so
powerful you know the performance of
girls in an all-girl School versus
mixing them with boys and what it did to
their overall performance
yeah but let me just finish look because
I remember going to a Catholic all boys
school and I remember the effects you
know that it's all boys and how you can
focus and whatnot and then going into
now a public school and not where it's
all mixed and I I I it was you know boys
the main thing on boy's mind was hooking
up with the with the girls
want to read that they've got to find
the old Edition the 2010 Edition because
the new edition
the publisher the editor uh persuaded me
to drop that it's gone oh and the reason
they did that is because single sex
education is not an option for most
Americans it's just not fewer than one
percent of American girls graduate from
a girls high school and I wanted to just
let me I don't I'm sorry I didn't
interjecting I just wanted to also bring
this up why because we still do that as
Muslims we still go ahead and separate
the men separate the women so I want
people to know I mean from a
psychological science and I still have
in chapter seven of that book the
importance of connecting girls to
community of women connecting boys to
community of men that final chapter so
the last three chapters of girls on the
edge are mind body and spirit and that
last chapter of spirit what a girl needs
to become a woman of faith is different
from what a boy needs to become a man of
Faith that's not a guess we got good
studies on this point but what both boys
and girls need is they need to be
connected to community
of adults girls need a community of
women boys need a community of men
that's what the religious community
needs to offer
and I actually have a a workshop for
communities of faith on on what teens
need what they don't need is a pizza
party for girls and boys together and
that's what unfortunately what many
communities offer it's not what they
need
girls need a community of women boys
need a community of men and when you do
that then you have strong bonds across
generations and that's what helps girls
to become Women of Faith that's what
help boys to become then of Faith
so that's still in there but the the
chapter on mind which used to be all
about the benefits of all girls
education is gone
and replaced with uh other information
about helping girls to be confident and
and assertive and all that kind of stuff
so uh do you remember do you remember
clearly there in the book I remember
vaguely you talked about how you know
the woman when men were present also you
know they were more about focusing on
attracting the boys and you know and
same thing with the boy the girl we have
we have a lot of those interesting
studies uh so one group of researchers
looked at girls in Chicago and also
girls on a Native American reservation
in Arizona or New Mexico
uh and they found when the girls were
just playing dodgeball in an all-girl
setting they were they were really into
it they were playing hard but the moment
The Voice came
many of the girls step back
because
sports are for boys and the girls just
stepped back and started talking to the
girls and the boys took the game over so
the co-ed format can really disadvantage
girls in many domains certainly that's
true in in sports certainly it's true in
computer science physics and Engineering
but again the publisher persuaded me to
drop that because
specifically girls schools it's just not
an option for most people living in the
United States and even in those cities
that have
uh girls schools most of them are
private schools that are often expensive
I did lead a group for many years called
the National Association for single sex
public education
and uh to to encourage more public
schools to offer Single Sex options and
uh when we started there were seven
girls public schools and one boys public
school in the United States when they
when we shut down in 2012 there were 70
girls Public Schools excuse me 110 girls
public schools and 70 boys public
schools which sounds like a lot but
there's more than 90 000 public schools
in the United States so it's still less
than one tenth of one percent yeah uh
it's just not an option for most parents
so that's why and we've helped we could
make better use of that chapter by
talking about some of this newer
research so uh but yeah for in the in
the spiritual domain in the religious
community absolutely you want girls with
women and boys with men that's what the
research says let's talk about this uh
wiring in the brain the studies showing
boys and girls are totally different
male and females hardwired the way
they're hardwired you know uh the how
they smell the same the the how they see
the New York Times publish your article
girls are better with odors 100 times
100K 100 000. that was more sensitive
here you know you have hearing smell
more than 400 scientific scholarly
references so my question here's my
question doctor have the people who are
pushing this man can be a woman woman
can be a man this uh gender is a social
construct have they seen these
scientific references these scholarly
references no with very few exceptions
uh so let me first of all summarize what
we're just talking about so if you
Google my name Leonard tax and New York
Times and stinky socks you'll find the
article I wrote for the New York Times
showing that indeed for many odors girls
and women have a sense of smell that's
much better than boys and men
a hundred thousand times more sensitive
in some cases so uh the man said the the
woman says oh my goodness it really
stinks in here I'm gonna throw up and
the man says I don't smell anything uh
and I think it's important first of all
for men and women to understand this
because otherwise the woman's really
angry she's like how could you pretend
you don't smell that it's incredible
it's overpowering how can you pretend
you don't smell like he's not pretending
he's telling the truth that man and the
woman need to understand that they are
experiencing different sensory worlds
uh and
profound differences in Vision hearing
and smell again this all comes from my
book why gender matters uh and
again when you debate as I have debated
people who are pushing this transgender
uh transgender activism
the great majority of these people have
never heard of this research and have no
interest in it they believe that male
and female are an invention of the
heteronormative patriarchy uh and that
anyone who thinks otherwise is an idiot
a Republican or both
uh so but are they aren't these people
who are like on certain other uh agendas
they were like follow the science
well there's a great contradiction there
because uh they follow the signs only
when the science aligns with their
politics uh and when it doesn't they are
ignorant and they have a remarkable lack
of curiosity uh or when you really push
the studies on them they will
desperately try to find some flaw
they'll say well that study was too
small or or those people had an agenda
they haven't read the paper though so
they're at Great uh uh they're at a
great disadvantage uh because their
criticisms are not valid these this is
really uh compelling work in another
study that I often cite when I'm asked
to speak on this topic researchers
recruited pregnant women in the third
trimester of pregnancy and did high
resolution MRI scans and the baby still
in the mother's womb and find very
dramatic differences between the wiring
of the boy's brain compared to the
wiring of the girl's brain
and it's not a matter of development the
two brains are developing along
different trajectories we are born male
or female
uh and then people say well but intersex
is just as common as red hair two
percent of of humans are intersexed
neither male nor female or both male and
female well um no actually not uh the
correct number is uh not two in one
hundred but uh less than two and ten
thousand five births are actually
intersex intersex is a very rare anomaly
and for people who are confused or want
to read the literature I advise them to
Google the phrase how common is intersex
the title of a paper I wrote for the
Journal of sex research one of my most
side hit papers uh showing that when you
add up the highest possible numbers for
these very rare conditions so for
example
uh XX and X Y embryo are fused and this
individual is is a is a mix of two
different chromosomal complements one
male XY the other female XX this
individual has both an ovary and a
testicle
uh producing both male and female
hormones a true intersex individual that
particular particular anomaly uh about
one in two million live births is
extremely rare but it happens and if
you're going to discuss this topic you
need to be prepared to talk about
intersex but the first thing to
understand is that intersex is very rare
it's less common than siamese twins then
come joined twins we don't develop a
Theory of Personality built around
siamese twins is the norm siamese twins
are not the norm they're a very rare
exception and The Theory of Personality
built on two heads sharing one body
would not be helpful because that's a
very rare uh anomaly it is not a normal
variation
uh intersex likewise is a very rare
anomaly it is not a normal variation
being left-handed is a normal variation
uh being intersex is not a normal
variation it is a a unique and unusual
pathology
uh and again that transgender activists
try to use intersex
as part of their ideological battering
ground to break down this intuition that
most humans have that we are either male
or female not both not neither
uh so if you're going to debate this
topic with the transgender activists I
encourage you first to read my paper how
common is intersex so that you're
prepared to say no intersex is not
common it's not as common as red hair
it's about as common as siamese twins
it's rare
can you just move uh your mic a little
away from your mouth it's creating just
a little bit of static there you go yes
okay yes thank you uh just a few more
questions uh before we conclude uh tell
me this um you were very courageous
enough and this goes back to I'm going
to use one word because we're family
friendly show but uh it kind of I have I
can't not use it because well I can if
but I just don't want to take away from
this powerful statement that you said if
you can elaborate on it he said it is
malpractice yeah to put that boy in a
dress change his name to Emily and then
prepare to cut off his balls Mel
practice to put a boy in a dress and
call him Emily and cut off his balls
yeah so the American Academy of
Pediatrics issued guidelines
Official Guidelines uh what do you do if
a if a five-year-old boy says he's a
girl or a 14 year old girl says he's a
boy and guidelines now say these are the
Official Guidelines from our nation's
leading experts
are that you are to immediately
transition if that five-year-old boy
says he's a girl you are to change his
name to Emily you're you're to change
the birth certificate to Emily Justin
never existed you're to put him in a
dress and he's going to school as Emily
and that will lead down the road that
leads to cross-sex hormones and
castration
what was the evidence
okay the the previous standard was what
was called watchful waiting so this boy
says he's a girl uh why do why do you
think you're a girl because I love
ballet and only girls like ballet well
actually some boys love ballet there's
nothing wrong with a boy liking ballet
and you can study ballet but you're
going to study ballet as a boy now
there's a girl
that was the previous standard prior to
the new guidelines the American Academy
now says that's bigotry if you do that
you're you're bigoted and you're you're
you're ignoring the evidence
what's the evidence that that watchful
waiting is is so harmful as conversion
they said watch what waiting is
conversion therapy and we know that
conversion therapy doesn't work and they
cited one study in support of their
claim that conversion therapy doesn't
work that one study was a study of adult
men
who were gay and wanted to be straight
and this one study showed that trying to
convert them from gay to straight didn't
work and I said in my comment which was
published by the American Academy of
Pediatrics is still on their website
uh
I said a study of sexual orientation in
adult men
is not relevant to the question of
gender identity in five-year-olds you
would think that pediatricians would
understand that children are not adults
and that a study of adults sexual
orientation is not relevant to
Children's gender identity sexual
orientation and gender identity are very
different things
but they did so the guidelines stand and
it's it's immensely harmful these
guidelines are immensely harmful
I was uh hired as an expert witness in
the case of a family whose 14 year old
daughter said that she's a boy
and the parents said no you're not a boy
we're not going to help you transition
to the male role and get you cross-sex
hormones and so Chic the child the 14
year old contacted Child Protective
Services
and they took her out of the household
and put her in foster care with a family
that would give her cross-sex hormones
and the parents sued said no we're the
parents we have the right to make that
decision where did this this happen here
in the U.S this happened in Arizona they
took the they took the this is happening
every day and this is happening all the
time in in California
they actually tell the kids in the
school hey if you want to transition and
your parents don't want you to come to
us and I'm your mom now as one teacher
in California said and and in many cases
what would but this case was Arizona
which is not as crazy as California yeah
keep it keep it there we hear you better
when it's here when it's by your mouth
so
I'm speaking one-on-one with a judge
and I'm I'm explaining look the research
shows that and this particular girl is
anxious she's depressed this is a
manifestation of her psychiatric
disorder it is not best practice how old
is she how old is she 14 years 14. they
took her out of the house they took her
out of the house and put her in foster
care and and the judge said yeah but
what's what are the official guidelines
of the American Academy Pediatrics I
said okay the The Official Guidelines of
the American Academy actors are you got
to deal with the girl wants you to do
and the judge said so Dr sacks you're
telling us that you know better
than the American Academy of Pediatrics
uh remind me again you're a family
doctor
you're not a professor you're just a
family doctor Dr sex you're asking me to
take your word
Over the official guidelines of the
American Academy of Pediatrics isn't
that correct
I said yes that's that's exactly what
I'm asking you to do she said I can't do
that you're just a family doctor
the city of American Academy of
Pediatrics and the parents lost their
suit they lost custody of their child
and this is happening and so it is not
just theoretical that the American
Academy of Pediatrics has been
politicized it's harming kids right now
kids who are being
mistreated
healthy girls are having mastectomies at
13 14 15 years of age
uh because they have been sucked into
this toxic American culture so again
you've got to be on your guard you got
to limit what kids are seeing on Tick
Tock and YouTube because American
popular culture has become really toxic
it's cool to be Trans in the United
States today
do you remember that uh have you ever
watched that show Sanford and Son
oh that's a long time you remember
Stafford's son when when he'd hear some
news he said oh it's the big one it's
coming it's coming
I'm telling you this would make you cry
you know this when you hear this it's no
exaggeration this is just just going
back to the heart this this uh really
you know for if your your heart is alive
you're conscious you're you're you know
a god-conscious person you're just a
good person who wants to live by some
morals you know what I mean you know
some
um you mentioned this is politicized
this has nothing to do with science you
know and you're one man standing up
against me God Almighty uh bless you you
know and and reward you tremendously for
taking the stand I'm just so like
impressed by this you know so what can
the community we had recently in Detroit
if you saw the news they were showing on
the news these books and they couldn't
show the images but then they're
sexualizing the kids by showing them
these images and then you saw the Muslim
Community stepped up you know Christians
also other people who are against this
they stepped up they unified came
together and they were working to get
these books out of there what's your
advice you know for for parents for
others you know what along with advice
you're giving you know when boards come
together are you know when people are
coming together to push this stuff on
the kids sexualization the kids at such
a young age yeah schools are important
and again I just did an interview for
The Epic Times about some of these books
that they're putting in the kindergarten
first second grade
teaching little kids that it's normal to
have uh two moms that it's if you are uh
that is courageous to be trans uh that
uh telling six-year-olds that if you're
not comfortable being a boy then maybe
you're a girl
it's wildly age inappropriate it is
harmful it is toxic it is deep
stabilizing
the male female
binary
is real there's a sperm there's an egg
anything in between is pathology if it's
not a sperm or an egg then it's not a
gamete and it won't work
that's okay that's the way God made us
and there's so much toxicity in what's
out there you got to know what's going
on in your school
and if you find the things are going on
that aren't healthy then you need to
reach out to other parents and approach
the school leadership with the other
parents don't ever try to do this on
your own
one angry parent is just a nuisance
10 angry parents can make a change so
reach out to other parents
uh reach across across face you know I
speak at Catholic I speak at synagogues
I speak at Muslim
they all know that we are children of
God
and we have so much more in common
than that unifies us so that we can
speak together across faiths and go to
that superintendent that principle and
say this is not acceptable the public
school needs to be accountable to the
public school parents and what you're
doing here
we will not tolerate there has to be a
change and you can do it you can make a
change
you have stepped across those boundaries
and you just said something brilliant we
have to work together you know reach
across and you've done that you can be a
you've been a shining example and I
think you know there's a lot of uh
people of other faiths out there who
feel as strongly as we feel but now
there's a lot of times it's hesitation
because all them Muslims you know them
terrorists and this that and the other
you know what I mean and I'm going to
play a quick quiz game with you to see
it's called did you know just before we
conclude but what advice do you have for
for others out there who'll maybe
they're still stuck in their town they
haven't got out to travel they're still
thinking these Muslims they want to chop
our heads off you know they're just that
and the other and whatnot and and we're
losing out because we're not able to
unify we're divided and we're not
working together to combat some of this
thing this attack on our children
well I think there's a lot of
stereotyping on on both sides I have
spoken in many rural communities
uh
and
you can change Minds don't give up on on
on your fellow human beings
um they you may encounter people who are
prejudiced against the Muslim Community
reach out to them talk to them you can
change their mind don't be discouraged
did you know I'm going to ask you this
before did you know that uh Muslims uh
it's an article that are Faith to
believe and love Jesus did you know that
Dr sex I believe that Jesus is regarded
as a prophet yes it's a mighty messenger
yes yes yes and uh did you know that
there's a chapter named after his
Blessed Mother uh called uh the chapter
of medium Surah medium in the Quran I
don't did you know this I I did I have
been gifted the Quran by a number of
Muslim communities and it has a special
place on my bookshelf and I just make
these points because this can be an
icebreaker these talking parts are so
important that you know when we say
Jesus we say peace be upon him we hold
him to such a high reverence obviously
we don't believe he's God or literal Son
of God but he's a mighty Messengers like
Abraham Moses and all the other
preceding Messengers who brought the
same message to worship one God the
Creator not the creation it's very
straightforward and I think this you
know when people know this that they
love our Jesus yes we love him as Muslim
we love Jesus this can hopefully soften
some hearts and we can get Beyond some
of these negative false stereotypes
God will I hope so I hope so too
inshallah inshallah God willing yes so
uh before we conclude now your books uh
the books uh are called why gender
matters uh boys adrift girls on the edge
you can't get that one that I've read
now huh it's still out there still out
there but it's it's way out of date
because you know a major focus of that
book is on the harms of social media but
Tick Tock did not exist when I wrote the
first edition so the second edition is
much more up to date I want to also
um have you do you visit Florida at all
of course so you've been to Tampa
I've been to Tampa on many occasions
I've spoken on many occasions for the
school district of Hillsborough County
sixth largest school district in the
United States and and all across central
Florida from Volusia County
um uh Daytona Beach DeLand to Orlando
and uh and Tampa absolutely you were
telling me about the other Imam uh what
was his name again he uh Anwar so he was
someone who recommended to board members
and others to bring you out and from
there people start bringing you up I
want to go ahead and call upon my
audience to go ahead and start bringing
you out and I'll be one of the first if
if not in Florida we've taken the dean
show we're looking thank God we have
acquired the properties called the dean
Center
foreign
[Music]
guys so we signed everything here
you gotta get the keys
[Music]
[Applause]
amount of Muslims around here it's it's
pretty huge and uh like this the place
the location that you opened and
basically it's far further south from
the other other big massages and
everyone I know a lot of people that I
used to I come my cousin lives nine
minutes from here another uh Uncle of
mine lives about five to ten minutes
from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
the center this Center is much needed
for this area and the idea of this
Center is needed for the whole stick
because we don't have anything like that
in the whole state that was sensor where
it's gonna basically nurture and
basically educate and it's gonna
basically spread Islam
now we're in the works of getting it
built up and God willing inshallah be
open uh and uh hopefully within a year
and then I like to start doing Live
Events there and bringing out people
like yourself and I want you also
hopefully when I send an invitation to
come on down to Tampa and uh do some of
your presentations and do a live show in
front of a live studio audience God
willing how's that sound I'd love to do
it I love it all right thank you so much
God bless you thank you for speaking the
truth thanks for inviting me all right
uh peace be with you as we say assalamu
alaikum thank you I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you are not yet
Muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedenshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum